PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUING TO
COUNTER PUNCH NANCY PELOSI WITH
A NEW TWITTER TAUNTS AS THE
SHUTDOWN FIGHT GETS PERSONAL.
AFTER GROUNDING HER MILITARY
AIRCRAFT YESTERDAY, THE
PRESIDENT SLAMMING THE HOUSE
SPEAKER FOR PLANING TO GO ON AN
OVERSEAS TRIP DURING THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
PELOSI'S OFFICE IS ACCUSING THE
WHITE HOUSE OF LEAKING
INFORMATION ABOUT PLANS TO FLY
COMMERCIAL CLAIMING IT CREATED A
SECURITY RISK.
THE WHITE HOUSE CALLS THE CHARGE
ASSANINE AND A FLAT OUT LIE.
>> IT'S VERY IRRESPONSIBLE ON
THE PART OF THE PRESIDENT.
WE WILL GO ANOTHER TIME.
THIS WOULD BE MY NINTH TRIP.
>> DO YOU VIEW THIS AS
RETALIATION ABOUT WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT THE STATE OF THE UNION?
>> I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
WOULD BE THAT PETTY.
>> IT'S A TALE OF 2 SHUTDOWN
STUNTS FOR THE MEDIA.
PELOSI GETS PRAISED FOR DELAYING
THE STATE OF THE UNION AND TRUMP
TRASHED FOR AXING HER FOREIGN
TRIP.
>> SPEAKER PELOSI FLEXING HER
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSCLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT RESPONDED IN A
CHILDISH WAY.
>> THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF TRUMP
OVER-REACTING.
>> SHE HAS A PHD IN NEEDLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WHAT TRUMP DID WAS INEPT AND
NITWITTED.
>> THIS IS POLITICAL GENIUS.
>> THIS IS A CASE STUDY IN MEDIA
BIAS.
>> IT'S A PRETTY GOOD EXAMPLE.
WHEN HE WAS QUIET FOR THE DAY,
AND SHE GOT ALL OF THAT PRESS
FOR A WHOLE DAY.
THE TIMING OF THE LETTER THAT
YOUR TRIP WAS CANCELLED COMING A
HALF-HOUR BEFORE THEY WERE TO
LEAVE, THAT WAS REALLY GOLD.
I DID MY SISTER TEXT.
TRUMP AND PELOSI TIRED OF IT!
THAT MAY BE HOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
FEEL.
AND ALSO WHEN PELOSI I DON'T
THINK HE WOULD BE THAT PETTY.
IT'S LIKE IN THE SOUTH WHEN YOU
SAY BLESS YOUR HEART.
>> YES.
I THINK IT COULD HAVE BEEN
WORSE.
I MEAN TRUMP CANCELLING THE TRIP
IS NICE.
IMAGINE IF HE ALLOWED THEM TO
GET ON THE PLANE AND THEN HE
WAITED UNTIL THEY WERE IN THE
AIR AND THEN REROUTED IT SO IT
FLEW IN CIRCLES UNDER THE U.S.
FOR 11 HOURS.
IMAGINE IF HE LET THEM FLY IN
THE AIR FOR 11 HOURS.
OKAY, LET THEM LAND IN D.C. AND
THEY ARE ALL TIRED.
THE AMBIEN IS WEARING OFF.
WOW, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT BRUSSELS
HAD A WHITE HOUSE.
HE DID THEM A FAVOR.
I THINK THE IDEA OF CALLING EACH
OTHER CHILDISH DOESN'T WORK.
EVERYBODY IS A CHILD NOW.
WE LIVE IN A TIME WHEN IT'S TIT
FOR TAT.
THERE IS A POSITIVE THING THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
I SAID IT YESTERDAY.
NANCY PELOSI HANDED HIM THE
GOLDEN KEY.
GET OUT OF THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
IT'S BORING.
THINK OF IT AS STATE OF THE
UNION UNPLUGGED.
GO BACK TO ITS ROOTS.
>> ACOUSTICS.
>> YOU SEND A LETTER AND HAVE A
RALLY.
EVERYBODY WINS AND WE SAY HERE
IN NEW YORK.
WE DON'T HAVE TO TAKE THE TRAIN.
AND LISTEN TO THAT BUBBLE -- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT I SAID.
>> IT'S ABOUT TRAVEL ANXIETY.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GO ANYWHERE.
>> THIS IS JUAN.
THIS IS NEWT GINGRICH TALKING
ABOUT PICKING A FIGHT WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEN YOU CAN REACT.
>> I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO IS
MORE PREDICTABLE AT
COUNTER-PUNCHING.
YOU HIT DONALD TRUMP HE PICKS UP
A LOG AND SLAMS YOU ACROSS THE
HEAD AND SAY SEE, YOU MADE ME
IRRITATED.
SHE HANDED HIM A HUGE SOFTBALL
AND SAID KNOCK IT OUT OF THE
PARK.
HE WILL SEND PART OF EVERY DAY
TO CAUSE HER PAIN.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS PLOTTING IN
THE OVAL OFFICE.
HOW ELSE CAN I CAUSE NANCY
PELOSI PAIN?
>> I THINK HE IS CAUSING HIMSELF
A GREAT DEAL OF PAIN.
I LOOKED AT THE POLLS.
IT'S CLEAR.
ALL OF THE POLLS INDICATE THAT
THE MAJORITY BLAME THE PRESIDENT
FOR WHAT IS GOING ON.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE SHUTDOWNS.
DON'T LIKE SHUTTING DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT AS A LEVERAGE POINT
FOR THE WALL THAT MEXICO WAS
GOING TO PAY FOR.
THEY THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REACH A DEAL.
IT WOULD BE NICE IF PEOPLE SAT
DOWN AND THOUGHT ABOUT THIS AND
WERE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE.
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE YOU
HAD REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
MAKE A DEAL.
McCONNELL SAID HERE'S THE DEAL.
IT WAS THE PRESIDENT WHO
SHUTDOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
YOU HAVE VICE-PRESIDENT PENCE.
JARED KUSHNER MEETING WITH MITCH
MCCONNELL TO FIGURE OUT SOME WAY
TO HELP THE PRESIDENT SAVE FACE.
WHEN HE DOES SOMETHING -- I
THINK PELOSI WAS CLEAR AND I
THINK THE STATE DEPARTMENT WHEN
THEY SAID YOU CAN'T GO -- IT'S
CLEAR HE DID TALK ABOUT THE
COMMERCIAL PLANS IN A WAY THAT
WOULD ENDANGER HER LIFE AND
EVERYONE ON THERE.
IN THE CONSERVATIVE MEDIA
BUBBLE, YOU REMEMBER ADAM
SCHIFF, THE PRESIDENT MISSPELLED
HIS NAME.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE WE ARE AT THIS
JUVENILE LEVEL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SAYING
ENOUGH OF THIS PLAYGROUND
BEHAVIOR.
IT'S NOT WHO WE ARE.
>> IT'S WHO WE ARE.
>> DR. SAPPHIRE, JUAN SAYS THE
POLLS INDICATE EVERYTHING BLAMES
THE PRESIDENT FOR A SHUTDOWN.
IF THE PRESIDENT GETS THE WALL
AND REOPENS THE GOVERNMENT,
WOULD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GIVE
HIM CREDIT FOR ENDING THE
SHUTDOWN?
>> WELL, OF COURSE.
HIS BASE WOULD BE HAPPY.
BUT THE OTHER SIDE WHO NEVER
SUPPORTS HIM WOULD COME UP WITH
SOMETHING ELSE.
HE WOULD NOT GET CREDIT.
>> THERE IS AN UP SIDE FOR THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I AGREE.
HE COMPROMISED ON THE COST OF
THE BORDER WALL AND COMPROMISED
ON DACA.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
WITH HIS CAMPAIGN.
HE LOWERED CORPORATE TAX.
BOMBED ISIS.
HE HAS TO DO THE WALL.
IF HE FOREGOES THE WALL, THE
REPUBLICANS WILL SUFFER.
IT'S ON BOTH SIDE.
PELOSI IS IN HAWAII.
COMES BACK AND SAYS SHE WILL
PULL THE REINS ON THIS AND HE
CANCELS HER TRIP.
GET BACK IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
STAY IN THAT OFFICE UNTIL YOU
FIGURE IT OUT.
YOU HAVE 800,000 PEOPLE NOT
GETTING PAID.
WHEN YOU ARE PRAISING THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HOW IT KEEPS
GOING DOWN.
NOW WE HAVE EMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS
NOT GETTING PAID.
THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
>> THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT WANT TO MAKE A
POLITICAL POINT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT BORDER SECURITY.
>> IT'S FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE GOT ELECTED SAYING HE WOULD
DO A WALL.
>> YOU ARE WRONG.
HE GOT ELECTED SAYING MEXICO
WOULD PAY FOR THE WALL.
WE ARE NOT NEAR THAT.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVED
THERE WAS A NEW NAFTA DEAL.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT.
YOU HAVE NOW THE PRESIDENT'S
ECONOMIC ADVISOR.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WE ALWAYS CUT HIM OFF.
>> THE FEDERAL RESERVE BANK
CHAIR IN NEW YORK SAYING WHAT IS
GOING ON IS SLOWING ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
THE PRESIDENT LET MRS. TRUMP FLY
AND WON'T LET PELOSI FLY.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WE DON'T NEED HER IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
>> OH, WE DON'T NEED HER.
>> IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO
SEE A SPECIFIC PLAN BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
NOW WE HAVE THEM ON RECORD
SAYING THEY ARE FOR ENHANCED
BORDER SECURITY.
THEY SAY IT NOW.
EVEN THOUGH THEIR LEADERS SAID
IT WAS IMMORAL.
WALLS WERE IMMORAL.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING IT'S MORAL.
WE NEED TO SEE A PLAN THAT SHOWS
A BORDER WITHOUT A WALL.
IF YOU WANT A DEAL YOU WILL HAVE
TO CREATE MONEY FOR AN ENHANCED
BORDER.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO COME UP
WITH A SPECIFIC DEAL WITH THIS
MONEY THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
WALL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS POSSIBLE?
JUAN, DO YOU BELIEVE YOU COULD
DO IT WITHOUT A WALL?
RIGHT IT DOWN RIGHT NOW.
I WANT TO SEE YOU DRAW IT OUT.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S SO HARD.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE!
>> GOING THROUGH THE ADDED
SECURITY.
>> BUT NO WALL.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOUR FAVORITE RADIO HOST
HOWARD STERN SAID IT DOESN'T
WORK.